quizás no laven muy bien seguramente
porque el ojo está atraído por los
escombros Pero hay una gimnasta en
equilibrio sobre el muro de este
edificio bombardeado en las afueras de
kiev un símbolo de la resiliencia y la
resistencia que recuerda un famoso
artista pero del cual nadie ha visto la
cara banksy
es el símbolo de que somos
inquebrantables y que nuestro país es
inquebrantable y a pesar de que esté
destruido lo vamos a reconstruir y todo
irá bien pero lo esencial es que somos
libres y podemos hacer de nuestro país
un lugar mejor pase lo que pase
desde hace varios días los rumores sobre
esta obra abundan en la red y fue
precisamente en Instagram donde el
artista británico reveló ser el autor en
el título solo se especifica la ciudad
borrovianca
fue uno de los primeros lugares en ser
bombardeados al comienzo de la guerra
también aquí es donde se descubrieron
obras similares especialmente esta pelea
de YouTube donde un niño derriba un
adulto encontramos el mismo toque el
mismo compromiso pero aún no se tiene
confirmación por parte del artista para
mí es increíble que banksy esté aquí en
Borja
este pequeño niño contra un hombre
adulto y que lo derrota y es así que
está pasando
no muy lejos de aquí en Irving también
se descubrieron otros dibujos queda por
ver si el artista se revelara no es la
primera vez que banksy se aventura en
terrenos de guerra para entregar un poco
de poesía en medio de los escombros